big massive dumps
dumps
congratulations sir you congratulations
sir you just won the election
[Music]
[Music]
sample trump saying massive dumps
song please do it
all right welcome everybody some
technical difficulties today
um oh no am i on
i think i'm on yeah no i was trying
actually a new uh like a voice
modifier thing before and did um
that was a joke by the way it just so it
did something weird it did something
weird but we've got i don't want to even
do too much with it because we've got an
entire new studio computer that's going
in
after i finish filming the friday show
this week and then we're starting
everything from the um
[Music]
from the beginning okay so that we'll
have a whole new setup and it's going to
work far
far better i did just just very briefly
i messed
around with some of the other sound
board drops that i have on my new
uh stream deck so just to show you what
we now have
and i'm just testing how it works we um
obviously there's gonna be much more
extensive work done with it
but we've got ymca
okay so at any point that could be dr
dropped in we've got three trump
fraud drops
okay so i've got those three and then
i've also added today
these four that's one of them
i've also got
wait you guys can't hear the drops
oh hold on a second desktop audio
monitor and output hold on a second
okay tell me if now you can hear it tell
me if you hear ymca
you got it okay good all right so we've
got the following ones
fraud fraud
it's a fraud so those we had from
yesterday
and then here are the new ones dumps
dumps dumps we got that one
they call them dumps they call them
dumps
okay big massive dumps big massive dumps
and then congratulations sir you just
won the election
okay so um anyway we'll continue to
build this up and if people want me to
add things i'm glad to do it
but we're just starting starting to drop
that stuff in okay big massive dumps
exactly so that's working well
we're why are we here today i often ask
myself the same question
um joe biden is set to make some big
announcements about
gun crime prevention and gun safety
regulations
now because a democrat is in the white
house republicans care about gun
violence again
really really important to understand
you can predict
whether republicans care about gun
violence by whether
there is a democrat or a republican in
the white house and there is currently a
democrat in the white house
so today anyway republicans care about
gun safety legislation they still don't
want to actually do anything about it in
terms of legislation
but they at least pretend to care okay
big massive dumps
so we're going to be hearing from joe
biden with some announcements
momentarily um i
want to oh paris says via super chat
you're a real pro at this
i know it's you know what this really is
fraud
that's this is a fraudulent stream
i have maybe the ugliest voicemail
i've ever received is that something
people would be interested in
in hearing about i'm willing to play it
this is a new caller we've never heard
from them before
um they did call without blocking their
number so the fbi already knows exactly
who they are uh they're gonna get a
visit shortly but
um this is what it is
listen here you little [ __ ] democrat
prick
now as many of you know i've never been
a democrat you're a short little [ __ ]
sucker
i take turds bigger than you that sounds
more of like a medical issue that's for
a medical show not this one
had the best president in [ __ ]
washington since reagan which was a
republican
and b actor but those were the best two
presidents ever
you're a little short little [ __ ]
[ __ ] that probably didn't make it
through [ __ ] high school
that's right i have no college degree no
high school degree yeah you you've
identified that exactly or maybe you've
got a community college uh
uh took voice lessons or something
i did i have a partial degree from
community college just for microphone
speech
speaking to a [ __ ] microphone but
nevertheless
you're just a little stupid little [ __ ]
don't you know that socialism
killed every [ __ ] country i'm not a
socialist i don't know why people call
me up and complain about socialism i'm
not a socialist
it's ever been implemented in and that's
what the democrats are pushing
what you think there's also i can't
think of too many democrats that are
actual socialists i think because
maybe you got some family money or
something you're gonna be okay
when this [ __ ] country gets crashed
there's no other free place to run you
stupid little [ __ ]
why don't you just [ __ ] off go and
[ __ ] hang yourself
crawl under a [ __ ] rock and stay
there you little [ __ ]
dear god what a little [ __ ] call a
socialist
to complain about socialism don't call
me
okay anyway so that person's done and uh
the call
was forwarded to authorities and we will
uh follow up as to what happens there
i want to say thank you to pizza man drc
a little punch drunk
polo dal sweaty taco
all of whom have signed up via join i'm
sorry via twitch
twitch and twitch prime and associated
twitch elements
you are new members one two three and
four
which we want to put up on our screen
there we go
new members one two three and four also
want to say
thank you to gary slooter who just
signed up on my website
joinpackman.com remember that you can
use the coupon code
celebrating the big news this week the
coupon code
cold feet crowder all one word all
lowercase
will um get you a massive massive
discount
big massive dumps and that will uh it'll
just save you such an amount i can't
even say
congratulations sir you just won the
election and that can be used
cold feet crowder all one word all lower
case
a few other super chats edgar points out
accurately
you never had audio issues until biden
took power i know i'm starting to think
it may be that
the biden stuff is responsible for the
audio issues the family says david do
you have two books you would recommend
any genre you found interesting lately
sure
um i'm reading infinite jest by david
foster wallace
right now enjoying it very much
also reading nick bilton's book on the
the genesis of twitter or as bernie says
twitter
and also quite interesting to see what
was going on behind the scenes at
twitter early on
just two books i'm reading right now
what do you think about desantis
executive order to teach the evils of
communism that'll be on tomorrow's show
i
flagged that story for tomorrow's show
i am mikey says you gotta add china and
stand back and stand by yes if someone
can isolate and
send me nice clean
drops of trump saying china in the
funniest way
as well as stand back and stand by i
will add them to the sound board i could
even do it if someone does it now i
could even add them
um during the stream and that would be
that would be super interesting let's
see
what else we've got thank you for doing
everything you do david out of curiosity
have you taken a political compass test
i've done it so many times
but i'm glad you mentioned that i'm
going to take a test right now
and from what i'm being told doctors
depending on how i do will be shocked by
what i uh what i do with this test okay
you know people often write to me and
they say sir
you were not they actually they say the
following congratulations sir you just
won the election
and i say i was i didn't even know i was
in the running so i really appreciate
that no
people say david where are you on the
populism scale because i have said
before i am not one of these
uh populists left or right as has become
popular now but what i do have here
is the guardians how populist are you
quiz if you want to take this along with
me
you can uh i guess search on google
guardian how populist are you
and my prediction is this is the scale
of populism so you've got
at the top the populist left and right
and at the bottom the non-populous left
and non-populist right
i actually don't think this is really
like
i i would sort of scale this a little
bit differently
my guess is that i would be to the left
of obama and macron so like if you draw
a vertical line here
i'm guessing i'm going to end up to the
left of obama and macron
but lower on the populism scale
than uh than these people that's my
guess
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna um take this
test
right now okay united states age
oh my god these are hard questions
gender all right let's continue
politicians should always listen closely
to the problems of the people
so always for me is complex
i don't i wouldn't say always but
generally speaking politicians should
reflect
the problems of the people so i'm
between agree and tend to agree
um i guess i would say
i agree with that politicians
don't have to spend time among ordinary
people to do a good job
so i don't think it's mandatory
that politicians spend time among
ordinary people to do a good job
i don't think it's necessary i also
don't think it's sufficient but i think
it's a good
thing so i'm going to say i tend to
agree
the government is pretty much run by a
few big interests looking
out for themselves you know it depends
on whether you mean
at the federal level at the state level
or at the local level
i'm going to assume it means overall it
doesn't say federal government and this
is also the guardian so
i'm going to interpret this as just
generally so i'm going to say i
tend to agree government officials use
their power to try to improve people's
lives again it depends on what
government you're talking about
federal state local um
i i tend to agree
that most people who get into elected
office
do it to try to improve people's lives i
think many of them fail
so i'm going to go with 10 to agree you
can tell if a person is good or bad
if you know their politics i think that
to a degree that's true if someone tells
you
my politics are white nationalism
a neo-nazi whatever um
i am unlikely to eventually find out if
i spend more time with that person that
that's what i would consider a good
person now the concept of good and bad
people is flawed to a degree
so i don't think i don't think strongly
agree makes sense
i don't think a gr i would say i tend to
agree with this
the people i disagree with politically
are not evil
some again concept of good and evil
sort of a black and white term i don't
know if i tend to see the world in this
way but accepting the question is asked
most of the people i disagree with
politically are not evil i've met some
that are
so i'm going to say tend to agree the
power of a few
these questions are kind of vague the
power of a few special interests
prevents our country from making
progress i am not as on board with that
as many populists are i
tend to agree but i don't agree or
strongly agree
a lot of important information is
deliberately concealed from the public
out of self-interest
uh man these are really vague
whose self-interest i would say you know
i don't
i don't know that i know that for sure i
guess i'll go with ten to agree
patriotism oof so
patriotism as defined by the right
i very much disapprove of there is a
version of patriotism that's okay
um the problem is it's been perverted so
it's really all an interpretation i'm
going to say neither approved nor
disapproved
nationalism i disapprove of
free market so with the free market i'm
fine with the free market
allocating resources in most areas but
not all
health care education to a degree
housing
um so i i tend to approve of the free
market when it's actually a free market
but not in all cases so i'll guess i'll
go with 10 to approve
free trade it's similar again it's like
when first of all
is it actually free trade oftentimes
people say free trade they mean
something else
um and not in all cases so i tend to
approve but i'm not like a big free
trade guy
renewable energy strongly approve
pollution control strongly approve
conservatism strongly disapprove
church authority strongly disapprove
left-wing people okay i'm on the left
i think there are some perversions of
the left authoritarianism as a problem
on the left
um some of this kind of like extreme
intersectionality that often ends up
being
anti-semitic or counterproductive
so i would say i'm beat i tend i approve
of left-wing people
is it tend to i tend to approve of
left-wing people yeah
socialism okay i am not a socialist
i don't believe socialism is
evil i don't uh you know i just i just
am not a socialist so i guess i would
say
i disapprove but not strongly
gay marriage strongly approve and
adoption by homosexuals
strongly approve all right let's see
where i am
where is david pakman wow
exactly what i predicted so
my thought was when i looked at this
that i would be to the left of barack
obama
but less populist than people like
bernie and amlo
exactly right so i think that this is
useful in the following sense
oftentimes people don't
know their own politics i've met so many
people who say
i'm a republican i just i'm just a
republican i say really what's your view
on taxes
what's your view on this what's your
view on that and they have no policies
aligned with republicans and they say i
guess i'm not a republican
i am reassured i've reassured myself
right that my thought was when i looked
at this
i'm going to be to the left of obama
but also lower on the populism scale
um so the the axes here are higher is
more populist
and left is more left and that's exactly
where i came in
i i figured i would be to the left and
lower okay that's where i was
so if you want to find this this is the
guardians how populist are you
quiz okay so we've got that
out of the way that'll that might be a
good clip
i want to say a huge thank you to logan
harriman
logan harriman just signed up on my
website with the coupon code
cold feet crowder i really appreciate
that logan your new member number six
today
i also want to say thank you to
political puppy for the twitch sub
a little punch drunk for the twitch gift
it's future man and no job
sully for the twitch subs that is uh
those are numbers seven
eight nine and ten and yes we're
celebrating the big sam
cedar events of the week with a coupon
code cold feet crowder
it saves you a huge amount huge huge
amount
let's see pepe xanadu i guess i missed a
message from pepe xanadu
are you and pat friends and besties pat
has his own social circle and i have my
own social circle
can you do a segment explaining the
difference between the pro act and ab5
and misinformation yes probably tomorrow
what's the update on the delta variant
in america big update on that on
yesterday's show
check that out what's the news about
ivanka abandoning trump
i will cover that on tomorrow's program
all right oh by the way speaking of
illegal discounts this is a really funny
image from a user independent nn
on the subreddit i love this this is
me in the white bronco of o.j
simpson fame see if you zoom in really
close
that's me right there and i'm driving
around and
evading police hold on a second how can
i zoom out here here we go
i've got lapd california highway patrol
is all over me on this one just
completely all over me
but i am just spreading the coupon code
as far and wide as i can
nice image i like that one that's a good
one
appreciate that um
let me see oh also thanks to marcus
lopez for signing up with the coupon
code
cold feet crowder at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate all of that support
uh what else did i have we don't have
unlimited time oh
okay yeah sometimes people get involved
in these really weird things with me
about the english language and listen
i'll be the first to tell you english is
not my first language uh
i i a couple of years ago was corrected
about
less and fewer and i i now understand it
i now make it a point
to um use the right term when
appropriate
people have been emailing me and they
seem to think
that i have made up a word mimetics and
they're saying the word is mimetic
these are two completely different
things guys okay
so when i'm using the term mimetics
oh my god look at this mimetics
as it says here is the study of memes
mimetics sees ideas as a kind of virus
sometimes propagating okay
so when i say mimetics or memetic
elements i am referring to
memes different word
mimetic okay mimetics is a noun we're
talking about
things mimetic is an adjective
that means imitative relating to
characterized by or exhibiting
mimicry when i say mimetics
and you email me telling me the word is
mimetic and it means something different
you are wrong okay you are simply
wrong it's a fraud please
stop the emails fraud no more
no more okay i am much more interested
by the way in mimetics
than mimetic stuff
no more emails please no more emails
okay i'm getting to most of my material
okay all right and then the the other
thing i wanted to look at so we did
populism quiz
i'm probably going to cover this more on
the um
program tomorrow but
there is this crazy thread from
gabriella border
who is a reuters reporter
this is from an event yesterday in
ashburn virginia
parents protesting critical race theory
my guess is very few of these people
know what critical race theory is but
let's
let's listen a little bit all they keep
doing is changing the narrative
clinical race theory is culturally
responsive framework
culturally responsive teaching it's all
just trojan horses inequity
diversity and inclusion you know come on
you know one thing after another after
another after another all right so not
making a lot of sense
um break in the critical race theory
protest
speaker up for the anthem
[Music]
indistinguishable from parody there's
more clips
this was inside
update former va state sen of virginia
state senator dick black
is that even real spoke out against
critical race theory
and the crowd couldn't stay silent
disgusting
[Music]
what the heck
isn't this just the worst um loud down
lowdown loudoun county school board
ended public comment
anti-critical race theory protesters
react
[Music]
[Music]
okay parents protesting against critical
race theory broke into the national
anthem again
when they ended public comment
[Music]
man this is really globally humiliating
this is just an embarrassment
the loudoun county sheriff's office
declared the school board meeting an
unlawful assembly
and said everyone will be trespassed two
arrests made
[Music]
the prospects in this country are really
really dim
here's a video of some dude getting
arrested i guess
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
i mean the room's empty it does seem to
be over
um yeah so it's
it's really pretty wild uh that's that
and i'll probably i have thoughts on
that
and i'm gonna talk about it tomorrow on
the on the broadcast program and all of
that
all of that stuff um people liking
the thumbnails on the
um new youtube channel yeah
we we announced that we had totally
transitioned over to the new thumbnails
and they're looking really good what is
crowder afraid of
jacques mac and cheese caller hates fat
people yeah that happened that's true
um yep so that's all happening
youtube.compacmanlive we are very very
close to our first
6 000 um followers in fact
let's see how we're doing on that 5740
yes so we're 260
subscribers away on pacman live oh
there we go another 10 beautiful let's
see if my button works which will link
in the chat to that
channel it did work beautiful
at least it's working on twitch
and there's another 10 dropping in
beautiful very nice
alright so that's all happening and
that's exciting
um do i have any other voicemails yeah i
probably do
electric sky says via super chat i took
the quiz and i'm slightly more populous
than you are
all right not bad here's a few other
uh voicemails as we wait for joe biden
so i was looking at the information of
um like how much
donald trump has as far as money and
then millionaires have together
and i was looking at this and it says
donald trump has 2.4 billion
and we're not even sure if he even has
that and then all the millions
all the millionaires together have 173.3
trillion dollars
so that's going on um
here's a troy york nonsense david
hackman you are
a podcasting shade girl
um i'm a shade gorilla did he say
are you keen socialist i'm argentinian
i'm not a socialist though
um i saw your video well
the headline i didn't bother where you
go matt gates
could be prosecuted oh okay if you're
just responding to a headline
i'm not even going to listen because
that's just a waste of time if you
actually want to watch a video and tell
me your thoughts that's one thing
um
[Music]
let's see what else we've got here
hi mr defender singh um
i'm just wondering um okay that one i
think i played on the last stream
okay i think we're pro oh hold on here's
one about sam cedar
yeah someone needs to tell sam speaker
perhaps you can and i hope you don't do
a video of this
that these protests against bolsonaro
are just
globalist health industrialist
propaganda to submerge
uh smurch both
[Music]
yeah we heard this yesterday too didn't
we yeah i guess i don't have that many
new voicemails
let's just see i'll give i'll give you
like a normal rand
a quote normal random voicemail hey
david
this is dave in california i hear former
president trump is going to mexico
which has now having
vice president harris go to mexico
before he gets there
on friday
what is trump hoping to gain
i think he wants to show at least his
base
that he's still president of the united
states
okay and then here's another one
uh hey david what's going on um so i
thought it occurred to me recently
now that all this information is coming
out about what was really going on
behind the scenes with trump and
everything um you know i've always been
very
anti-war i've always been anti they're
like you know working class uprisings
and everything like that
what do you i cannot believe that
apparently
it's been the general so this goes on
for three minutes and that's why it
never makes it onto the show because
it's a three when do i play a
three-minute voicemail
you know the the odds of you getting a
voicemail on the show
like the broadcast show the podcast the
radio show that type of thing
it goes up tenfold probably a hundred
fold if your voicemail is under a minute
there's people who do a full three
minutes and then do
another three minutes it's like dude
it's not getting on
it's not getting on alright nicholas
says i sent over clips for stream deck
info email yeah let's try these
um so we've got a china one
and china two
let's see i'm gonna drag these into my
stream deck
let's see if we can do it china one
and china two let's see
china all the time china
that's a good one china that's nice
all right thanks very much nick so we've
added those in
um beautifully
beautifully done
china all the time china
yeah that's what it is okay good
appreciate that
um do you fill out a t-shirt or do you
swim in it hun okay john says which
cryptocurrencies are you invested in
david
bitcoin and ethereum bitcoin and
ethereum and then i've got
um a bunch of doji coin
from a long time ago and i know it's
down i don't care you know
i'm just holding it i'm holding it all i
uh i've already sold enough
of the ethereum and the bitcoin that i'm
up multiple times
on the initial investment i know it
might all go to zero i'm just holding it
and we'll see what happens
um not uh not hugely worried about
it um
very good tell my mom to get back to
work says zack
okay zach's mom please go to work rb
empathy says i vote liberals support gun
rights for hunting and protection
but believe in gun control on weapons
that serve no purpose beyond mass
killing that's most of my gun-owning
liberal friends
um yeah not
not a big shocker i also want to say
thank you to anthony
hekanova who just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com
we do have a coupon code this week in
celebration of this wild wild event that
took place with sam cedar
stephen crowder and ethan klein the
coupon code is cold
feet crowder it's all one word and it's
all lower case
it works on any membership at
joinedpakman.com
cold feet crowder i also want to thank
hippie chick
aunty yuliha ultra butt
puncher big pun
all of whom just signed up via twitch
new members 13
14 15 and 16.
via twitch and please remember if you
are an amazon prime
subscriber and you're not using your
twitch prime subscription that you get
every month
you're leaving money in jeff bezos's
pocket that could go to a streamer that
you like or even that you don't like but
you
value in some way um so i'm not saying
you have to use it
on this channel but you don't leave
your twitch prime subscription unused do
not do it
do not do it joseph gundell says big fan
david thanks
arnold says your shirtless pics on
instagram
are inspiring ripped i know
i have so many shirtless pictures on my
instagram people should definitely be on
there
derek leland says check out the vic
berger desantis trump video
i would check that out vic burger
desantis trump
um june 13th is this the right video
let's see if this is it as we stand by
for uh joe biden let's take a look at
this video our most valuable player mvp
governor for conservatives ron desantis
of florida
talking about the press and fake news
okay
i don't trust the premise of the
question but yes i would like to see
some validity
to what they're saying before i indulge
the premise thing that showed that their
narrative was a piece of horse manure
it's so insulting when they write funny
stories that they know a fake news
because they're not insulting me they're
insulting everybody
that have worked so hard so long that
are thinking
about nothing other than this invisible
enemy
our peak hospitalized census for covid
patients was about 9 600 over the summer
and it shows you how
dishonest these are smear merch from
sick people
and they put that breath together so
that's why nobody trusts
corporate media
would anybody like a pen would anybody
there is definitely a similarity in the
mannerisms there
nicely done yep i i approve of that
that's a pretty good one
um liking it other super chats coming in
hey david what are your thoughts on what
happened with the further people ask act
last night my lead story on today's
podcast is all about that so i'm going
to try to avoid duplicating content but
that's the lead
story on today's podcast tv show radio
show the whole thing
charles says these right conservative
figures will never go on the types of
left-wing platforms that actually
challenge them substantively on policy
issues or history in general
mostly true some of them will but mostly
that's accurate
big thank you to a whole bunch of people
dumping in some twitch subscriptions
i want to say thank you to geek girl the
savage minion
mr president jesus lagubrius
it's gimli and g blas and rock
that is six putting us at 22 today
loomisom says via super chat john mcafee
has been allegedly found dead by his own
hands
according to spanish news he said he had
no intention to do so i don't know
anything about it i couldn't possibly
comment on that right now
where should i start to learn about
democratic socialism and social
democracy what are best authors
i would maybe start with the very short
uh what do they call the very short
introduction series just get the one on
socialism
there's probably some let's see very
short
story very short introduction socialism
yeah get socialism a very short
introduction
get uh maybe there's some others and
then look at the sources
for that little book and then go and get
yourself some of those books
that's often a good idea david newton
says
emailed eight more trump china clips
uh-oh
let's see what else we've got um let's
see if i can make any use of these
we're gonna on the fly add some clips
here
eight clips it looks like there's only
two
yeah i'm only seeing two but i'll drop
them in and we'll see what we get
hold on let me go into my drops
this is all gonna have to get
reorganized let's see
china china
it's not racist at all no not at all
i think that would be good like maybe
during a rally where you know that
sheriff clark
comes up and says horrible things and
then we drop in it's not racist at all
no
not at all okay appreciate that thank
you
again we're switching over to a
completely new computer system
in the studio by after this week so we
will um
we'll we'll have to rebuild everything
after that point in time
other super chats coming in
denny says why didn't you take a selfie
with me when i asked
oh i don't know what that's about joe
biden is a neo-liberal corporate
corporatist
if you're i think you mean if you were
on the left at all you would do a lot
more criticisms of him please hold joe
biden accountable my lead story monday
was a criticism of joe biden
in the clip today about the voting
rights act i criticized joe biden i
think that
i i may be going out on a limb here guys
but i think
it's possible possible
that um people may be criticizing
things that do or don't take place on
the show without actually watching the
show
mcafee dead spanish prison suicide
i guess it's true i guess it is true
he did say if i recall correctly that he
did not plan to kill himself
but maybe he did and he said it
let's see here john mcafee
two hours ago his extradition was
approved
and now he has been found dead in a
spanish prison
it is a new york post report and you
know the new york post is
is essentially fox news um people may or
may not know that
antivirus software pioneer john mcafee
dead after prison suicide antivirus
software tycoon john mcafee died by an
apparent suicide in a spanish jail cell
wednesday evening
hours after reports surfaced that he
would be extradited to face federal
charges in the u.s
according to local media the eccentric
tech entrepreneur was arrested in
october
and was awaiting extradition when he was
found dead police sources told the
newspaper el pais that's the spanish
newspaper the newspaper reported mcafee
was pulled from his cell in barcelona
and police are investigating the
circumstances around his death
mcafee was hit with a 10-count
indictment earlier on wednesday the
spanish high court had agreed to
extradite mcafee
who has been charged with a number of
federal
financial crimes in two districts in the
united states
also charged in a separate indictment in
manhattan federal court in march for a
pump and dump scheme involving kryptos
that is everything that is known so far
daily beast i'm told also has it
let's see here
mcafee dead in spanish prison now do
they just quote the new york post
no spanish newspaper el mundo let's take
a look at that
oh no i guess i gotta accept ads here
ads and cookies
everything points to what could be
treated as a death by suicide
prison authorities assure us
prison authorities have confirmed that
the american magnate
john mcafee creator of the famous
antivirus of his own name
has been found dead in his cell which he
occupied in the first module of the
centro penitenciario de brian's dos
he was 75 years old this morning
the national audience nacional uh
finally gave the go-ahead to extradite
mcafee to the united states
wow that is uh i mean listen
i think he had recently said he was not
going to be killing himself
but he did not strike me as a guy that
was well so i don't know what to make of
it
i don't know what to make of it but it
is something
certainly we will be uh looking into
maddie sancho says please play the song
nobody cool likes tucker carlson by
okay we're not going to do that right
now but maybe at another point
krtd hold corporate dems as accountable
as republicans
smear man says running is doing nothing
for your bicep
girth wow jacob ratner says sir have you
hold on oh sir congratulations sir you
just won the election
sir have you heard of the essay for four
americas by george packer in the
atlantic it argues we're in a cold civil
war interesting and good read i have not
read it i should
i will why are you afraid to support
assange i
really don't think about julian assange
bikwa says lib left on the political
compass also a gun owner
i think that the mass shootings we have
are a symptom of a cultural
sickness i agree with you but that
doesn't mean we do nothing about gun
safety regulations the u.s
has a gun culture problem but we also
have a gun availability problem
and we also have a gun regulation
problem
i am completely on board that if we
didn't have all of those things we
wouldn't need more regulations but we do
and we're not going to fix the cultural
problem too many people in the united
states
see guns as a way to solve
interpersonal problems political
problems social problems cultural
problems
that's the reality and there's no
changing that
quickly and so more things need to be
done
as we stand by here for a joe biden's
announcement on gun safety we have an
idiocy problem we really do
there's no other way to say it i want to
say thanks to a couple of the twitch
subscribers
chuck makes it oh just chuck okay thank
you
appreciate that chuck thank you very
much chuck
makes it has subscribed for six months
via twitch
oh hold on uh i missed one
crazy nate says hey david i recently
bought a helix mattress with a coupon
code pacman
i love my helix mattress i've never
slept so good
it must be so well right never slept so
well until i got it seriously that's
great to hear though
ryan says i was in san pedro belize and
the locals there shared a lot of insane
stories about mcafee
there they pronounced his name mac
coffee mac
coffee i like that was tucker carlson
another version of deep throat
in some strange sense i guess
in some strange sense i guess i also
want to say thanks to
mutiny who has just subscribed via
twitch
and his new member number 24 today
very much appreciate that let me grab
a couple other clips here that i wanted
to play for you
let me just find my folder
i apologize i should have been more
prepared
uh hold on a second
i did want to pull up the tucker thing
just reminded me
wait where is the tucker clip
oh yeah
this is really weird tucker carlson was
talking about
something in don lemon's kitchen i
haven't seen this i wanted to see what
this was about
seems very weird
my ad blocker seems to just it's like oh
there we go mr don lamont is a cable
news host on our competitor over at cnn
and most of the time he talks about
cable news host type things what the
royals are up to
how a commercial airliner might have
flown into a black hole you know the
news
is that really what don lemon's show is
i mean i i don't really watch any of
this stuff
but is that actually what don lemon
talks about it seems unlikely
but don lemon is most importantly more
than that
don lemon is a civil rights leader and
just the other day he spoke to the
washington post
is that even true about his feelings on
civil rights and he declared you may not
be surprised by this that america is a
racist country
quote we're living in two different
realities as black and white people
said father lamont it was interesting we
read that and we thought well here's a
guy who makes millions of dollars a year
for presiding over a show that is
failing that seems like a pretty good
deal but
like so many donald hasn't tucker lost
so many advertisers that fox is out of
pocket on his show like is that
isn't tucker's show losing money but
it's just it's good for fox because he
has ratings but they don't have
advertisers mon is also a victim
a successful victim and so we asked on
the victim scale on the scale of say
meghan markle to michelle obama just how
oppressed
is don lamont what is the different
reality he is forced to live in
as a black man in america well we did a
little digging
and hear the details don lemon
lives in a 4.3 million dollar home in
sag harbor harbor new york
no why would you even say the city he
lives in like sag harbor is not that big
i don't even why why would you even do
that
there's without a question based on the
number of thoughts i get
there's no doubt that don lemon gets a
ton of threats like why would you even
do this story
he does not live in section 8 housing he
lives in one of the whitest towns in
america in fact
80 percent sag harper is just three
percent
african-american now in the interview mr
lamont said america needs to see more
people like him
he regularly lectures america about
diversity
what he didn't tell the washington post
is that in his free time he runs away
from diversity his reality didn't tucker
move to maine when the pandemic started
is that he doesn't like diversity at all
none of them do
but here's the most troubling discovery
about mr lamont now you have heard from
the white house from the president
himself that white supremacy
is a lurking threat you might not always
see it but it's oh this i mean i'm
guessing that this will be a critique
that there's
you know this white face uh blackface
what is that like a salt shaker or
something uh on
in his kitchen come on this is so stupid
i mean it's you know i i do think that
it would be different for a white person
to have that in their kitchen
than a black person although in either
case you could plausibly argue
that like it's a relic from a different
era and it's a reminder like i could see
as
as a black man that don lemon would be
like this is a relic from another era
i have this in my nice house i now have
the nice house but this is a rem like
it just seems so stupid always there
like russian spies white supremacists
come in the dark of night in the most
surprising form they're shape-shifters
now we're not calling anybody a white
supremacist here
but you have to ask yourself i want to
put this on the screen now
what is this this symbol of hate
symbol of hate posing as a cookie jar
this is painfully dumb doing in don
lamont's kitchen
do you see that that right there ladies
and gentlemen
is a white supremacist q supremacist
went on cookie jar now we're not calling
for the department of justice to look
more deeply into this because that's not
our place
we're a cable news show not a law
enforcement agency
but let's just put it this way if you
find yourself with a blackface cookie
jar
in your own kitchen
it's time to reflect that means you
don lemon hey sean hannity that's really
really dumb
i mean painfully stupid i guess it's a
cookie
cookie jar okay fine uh but that is
really
really dumb um i don't even feel the
need to say much
it's not yeah it's it wasn't exactly a
slam dunk attack on don lemon
bizarre um
mikey sent a message via super chat but
then retracted it
issued a retraction or a traction
as uh as some may say oh i now somebody
sent me the stand back and stand by clip
let me see if i can get
that loaded up uh oh no but you sent me
a video clip
i need an audio clip yeah you sent an
mp4 needs to be an audio clip all right
otherwise i mean they're audio drops
um china it's not racist at all no
not at all right it's got to be audio my
friends audio
is tucker carlson mispronouncing don's
name a dog whistle no it's not
i think he's just making fun of him
that ryan dude says at times i envy the
right wingers making so much money to
get on tv and say nothing of substance
seems like a good gig if you can get it
certainly
um i wouldn't i wouldn't deny that
oh you can rename an mp4 to an mp3 is
that true
i did not know that let's see if we can
try that
rename an mp4 to an mp3
and then we will add it
let's see if that works stand back and
stand by
it worked beautiful beautiful
i love the assist that's a great clip
what is playing right now
stand back and stand by the clip is 50
seconds long for some reason even though
i think that's all
that's the only thing that's on it did
renaming it add 40 seconds of silence or
something
i hope not stand back and stand by
okay i guess i have to manually stop it
but that's okay that's okay
still like it does tucker actually
believe half of what he says
i think he probably believes about half
of it yeah
roughly roughly half of it um
you know this thing happens when i go
live and sometimes play voicemails
where people start leaving voicemails
while i'm streaming because they see it
as an
opportunity to get on sometimes with
really wacky stuff
so as a policy matter i tend not to play
them but i am sort of curious because
people are just dumping these in
let's see david nina
kansas city why is everybody still
talking about trump he hasn't been
president and
what forever i get it he was a jerk
i get it uh you know they're all kind of
jokes really
um tyt sucks
and jimmy dorrock oh it's a jimmy door
person i got you okay
fair enough all right here's another one
hey david
i saw your video a few days ago
and uh this is mainly a question about
reparations
and i just want to ask you is there a
time limit
on like debt to be repaid
and like all the things that happened
for like 300 years of slavery
you'd have to ask a reparations advocate
you know i i've said that i think that
the reparations should be more
fixing the structural inequalities and
that throwing cash at people
um does not seem to me like a way to
sort solve a problem
um i don't know why people direct these
questions
i mean i just ask someone who has
i don't know who you're responding to i
guess is what i'm saying
um i mean really that's just i think
where a lot of people follow on that is
that uh you know just because it
happened
150 years ago 200 years ago and people
were never paid out for it doesn't mean
that they shouldn't be paid for it
i don't know why you're arguing with me
i just don't know
um julio says hello are you a feminist
if so how do you respond to feminists
who say that true equality is not
possible under capitalism only through
socialism or a form of left
libertarianism
um yeah that i mean that's a more
marxist uh i am not a marxist feminist i
am a
small f feminist in that i am for
equality under the law
and equality of opportunity i think it
would be completely unreasonable to
expect a quality of
outcome if the goal is to have every
profession
be exactly divided 50 50
men women i i think that that's
unreasonable i think that you can only
do that through an extremely
authoritarian
imposition that makes no sense
whatsoever so i'm a small
f feminist and
i am not a marxist so uh
you know you'd have to go talk to
somebody who believes that
i i really i know it's not i'm not
attacking people but
i really find it boring
to respond to critiques of things i
haven't said like this is maybe not an
example because they're saying
am i a feminist um
[Music]
yeah okay i'm mikey says i feel like the
mispronunciation of the names of people
of color is just a super petty way for
racists to show disrespect
they do it with ayoke all the time
that's a joke that's me joking and doing
the thing you're saying they do it with
aoc all the time
i think they genuinely don't know how to
say
um alexandria ocasio-cortez's name
i actually don't know that it's
deliberate
frankie says how did buff get a
socialist to win an election before a
city in california i'm confused
what i think tucker got into
parliamentary debate which has no
morality
all right crazy nate says david have you
heard of brian tyler cohen's don't be a
mitch
fund i have not i don't know what that's
about
i do however want to say thank you to
trisha north star
for the twitch subscription you're
number 25 today
and just a reminder for anybody who's
just joining us right now
we have a very special coupon code this
week
cold feet crowder if you know you know
cold feet crowder is a coupon code at
joinpackman.com not only do you get all
the cool benefits of being a member
including that i suck up to you
but um i uh um you get a huge discount
you get a huge discount as well okay
people asking me to check in on the
pacman live
count let's see where we are uh oh we
had a bunch
okay my goal was to get to 6 000
subscribers on the new youtube channel
today we're now 180 away
i'll paste the link in the chat a couple
of times
you can also just go to youtube.com
pacman live this is an
all new channel new channel different
content
no overlapping content with the clips
uploaded to our main channel
people are going crazy uh i've even
gotten emails from people saying
some of the stuff you're posting is
almost too edgy
there's another 10 subs that dropped in
yeah i would love to get to 6 000
because it's an arbitrary round number
we're only 170 away
we'll keep an eye on it and we are
standing by for joe biden momentarily
now friday on the friday show i'm going
to have a commentary
someone wrote to me and said uh david
what can democrats do to better appeal
to rural or rural voters depending on
your
preference on the pronunciation one of
the things is
democrats have to drop counterproductive
rhetoric
on gun safety there is much to be done
on gun safety and it should be done and
much of the country agrees with a lot of
the different stuff
but democrats in many parts of the
country
are shooting themselves in the foot on
gun safety stuff particularly
when there's very little to be done at
the level of government for which they
are running
so i'm going to be talking about that on
the friday show i've already started
putting together some notes about it
and i think it's going to be i think
most people will
generally speaking agree with what i say
but
um there will certainly be some
controversy to it
look at this we are now only 110
subscribers away
from 6 000 on the new youtube channel
let's even check it out uh whoa hold on
a second
pacman live
um caller hates
fat people is a clip that's generating a
lot of comments
and it is a pretty aggressive caller
what is crowder afraid of this is a oh
this is a review from yesterday wow
we're really turning this stuff around
quickly we're doing a hell of a job here
uh good okay but yeah so that's the new
channel
and we'll check back in momentarily as
we stand by
for joe biden here uh
okay one more voicemail for you
hi david on your live stream you said
that
uh this is instant reaction like this
just happened parker carlson calling
don lemon don lemon is not a
dog whistle it's a just just he's
making fun of him in some way but it's
not a a
dog whistle i'm not sure what you mean
by dog what's up i guess racist dog
whistle is the way i'm interpreting it
and if i interpreted that i completely
disagree
this is just like what they're doing
with kamala harris
calling her kamala because they're
trying to make these people look
other they're trying to make them look
foreign and exotic
i think that there are some people who
deliberately mispronounce
kamala harris's name but i think there's
some who just don't care enough to know
what it really is
now you could argue that that's just
it's it's just thinly veiled racism as
opposed to over racism like i get that
but i think that you're overstating the
intelligence of a lot of right wingers
and we learned we shouldn't do that and
like in 2016 we learned that that's not
something to be done
it's certainly disrespectful whether
it's
racist or thinly veiled racist or just
kind of ignorant
i think it varies depending on who
you're talking about i want to say thank
you to stratomaniac as well as
elion113 who just signed up via twitch
and our new members 26 and 27 today
uh very much appreciate that and
i see one message from someone saying
the coupon code cold feet crowder isn't
working
you're typing it with spaces in the chat
if you're typing it with spaces on my
website it won't work because it is
all one word all together you gotta run
it all together no spaces one word
cold feet crowder it must be that way
uh okay people asking for another tucker
clip
actually and then also people asking for
a shapiro clip let's look at a shapiro
clip because we've not done that for a
really long time
let's take a look at everything whoa
let me see here
the washing oh hold on all right let's
see what ben should be i haven't seen a
shapiro clip for a long time
see what we got here
i'm preparing for it
mr don lemon we just watched this that's
weird
oh i guess i got i guess i copied the
wrong clip hold on a second
let me find the right clip ben shapiro
this one all right this one this one
let's see what he did on his show today
curious what's going on on that show
what is happening it's like the ad
blocker just it's like the ad blocker is
not doing super well
like i don't have to watch the ads but i
have to watch the washington post
concludes that higher numbers of black
traffic deaths are the result of
infrastructure racism before the people
act dies in ignominious
death to the whales and teeth gnashing
of the media and don lemon declares
himself
bias free i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
what's up with the kind of shaking of
his head like that that's weird
i didn't know that he was doing that
higher fuel prices higher food prices
construction cost housing prices
inflation is here have you protected
your savings your investments
if you haven't yet diversified a portion
into precious metals the answer is
you have not so i'm going to tell you
again if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
he's doing gold
okay or 401k into a precious metals ira
do it today text ben 240 precious metals
ira oh boy 747.47 get a free information
kit i'm protecting your savings with
gold
i buy my gold from birch gold because
they have an a plus rating with the
better business bureau account with five
star reviews over 10 000 happy customers
talk to them ask all your questions get
informed and then decide
if you want to put some of your money
into precious metals to work with birch
gold text ben's
we make a purchase before june 30th
birch gold will send you a signed copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three years
for free while supplies last again text
bench 47 47
47 and protect your savings today again
text my name ben to 47 47 47
already we're going to get to the
washington post bizarrest racial take of
the day and
there is one pretty much every day first
i got to give you the update
on what just happened in the new york
city mayoral primary so
there is a republican side of the aisle
where curtis sloa
just won the republican nomination but
let's be real about this whoever wins
the democratic nomination in the city of
new york
is going to end up as mayor of new york
because new york has now engaged in what
it calls ranked choice of voting
this isn't even that interesting like i
expected i expected that it was going to
be
unhinged but kind of compelling but i'm
finding myself kind of bored by it
that means that you can win the most
votes in the first round but you may not
end up as the overall winner
because let's say that somebody who had
10 percent
loses and the second choice on that
person's ballot was the person who came
in
second well then the vote shifts to the
person who is second now
realistically this race is pretty much
over because the number of ranked choice
voting situations in america where
somebody has a 10-point lead
after the first round where that person
ends up losing is pretty much zero
according to harry enten over at uh at
cnn new york times
eric adams appears to be the winner at
this point eric adams
who uh of course is the former police
yeah i believe he's a former police
officer and thanks to aristocracy for
the raid on twitch by the way
i am surprised i haven't seen a ben
shapiro clip for a long time
um i'm kind of surprised this is what
his show is like
i have to tell you and a uh uh rather
moderate candidate at least
so far as new york city goes he is
leading right now in the clubhouse about
30
coming in second somewhat shockingly is
maya wiley who
until recently was considered sort of an
also ranch was the only member of de
blasio's administration
to actually run she was occupying the
left lane so i guess it's not really
that big a surprise that about 20
of voters showed up for maya wildly
since everybody else was trying to crowd
each other out of the technocratic
moderate lane so adams ended up at about
30 widely ended up at about 21
catherine garcia i'm finding this
analysis pretty boring
let's see him talk about washington post
talks about rhodes are racist
and this goes to the deeper point and
the deeper point here is that when you
attribute everything
in the world it's meismetic forces of
racism it makes it very very difficult
to solve problems which of course is the
whole
point when you make problems difficult
to solve and then you implicate the
entire system
the notion is that you're going to have
to tear down the entire system in order
to solve the problems
everything has to be nuked you have to
just tear down everything and then
finally
once we have salted beef this is not
sped up this is not sped up
earth and and burn the remains of the
old system then we can build the new
except that that doesn't actually solve
problems that makes things a lot worse
in the near term so perfect example
today
in the washington post there's an
article in the washington post is at the
top of their website today
titled traffic deaths increased during
the pandemic the toll fell more heavily
on black residents
report shows a new analysis found that
even before 2020's increased black
people were killed on roads
on roads at a rate almost 25 higher than
white people
now let's just say that you read that
stat
right that for a very long time black
deaths on roads have outpaced white
deaths
on roads now i i just want to interject
something here
um there there is a
there's a there's a conversation to be
had here
so this is going through from my
experience in new york and boston
one thing i've noticed in
more highly non-white neighborhoods in
new york
and boston is that the
the road design does
seem to it wouldn't shock me if the
design of the intersections
led to more traffic accidents and what i
mean by that is
if you drive in some of the
predominantly non-white neighborhoods in
brooklyn
if you drive in some of the
predominantly non-white neighborhoods in
boston i'm not saying it's because
there's non-white people it's really
probably
a lot because these are poorer
neighborhoods
uh in boston you know places like um
uh matapan and um
parts of dorchester and and right etc
same thing in certain parts of of uh
brooklyn like brownsville etc
you you have a lot of intersections
where they look like they should be
four-way
stops uh but they're not but
sometimes it's not super clearly marked
as to which direction of traffic is
supposed to stop
and when i would drive and approach
these intersections
i would slow down no matter what because
they seemed like the perfect places for
somebody who's supposed to stop to just
blow by
counterpoint a lot of these
neighborhoods have intersections
that should be four-way stops because
you've got parking on both sides
really limited visibility or there
should be a traffic light altogether
and they're not four-way stops and these
seem like dangerous intersections and
this is an anecdotal observation
that i identified in both brooklyn and
boston area neighborhoods and i would
notice
it feels as though there's way more
situations in these neighborhoods as i
drive around
where i could get into an accident where
the only real way for me to avoid it is
to basically slow to a crawl
at every crossing whether or not there's
a stop sign and whether or not there's a
traffic light
so even just from hearing the
introduction to this story
to caricature it as roads are racist
that seems kind of dumb
but just thinking of my experiences in
new york city in boston i'm already
thinking of some things where if you
said to me could you imagine a way in
which the road design leads to more
non-white deaths
yes i could uh and i just explained it
okay let's continue
your first thought might be who's
speeding
right i mean that might be your first
thought that would be a natural thought
in the same way
that wasn't my natural thought that if
you read a statistic that said
that black people are being murdered at
a rate far higher than white people and
we know that the vast majority of murder
is intra-racial it is black on black or
white on white
but black people are being murdered at a
way higher rate you might think to
yourself
well that's probably the reason is that
a lot of black people are murdering a
lot of black people
so if you see a stat in which it says
that a lot of black people are dying in
traffic accidents
you might think to yourself what is the
behavior of the drivers right because
you would think that
that's literally your first question
forget about groups with regard to
individuals
right if you hear that anybody has died
of anything your first question is what
were the circumstances surrounding their
death
this is true for anybody's death if
somebody you know dies in a car accident
yeah i don't know i mean having read a
bunch of uh there's actually a really
interesting book let me see uh
what's the name of the book
uh there's a really good book about this
that i read not that long ago
hold on what is the name of this book
it's like tom
is it wayne right
no that's narconomics there's a book
about traffic
look let me see what it is
ah tom vanderbilt traffic why we drive
the way we do and what it says about us
which points out and in fact i think
that this
i think that this super chat is getting
a lot of the same thing applying traffic
calming techniques or a relatively newer
field in public administration and urban
planning
obviously more affluent and modern
neighborhoods would have the most reason
to sign applied yeah
there's a lot of things that are done to
um
psychologically make roads safer and
this includes
the width of the road relative to the
width of the sidewalk and the placement
of bike lanes and what uh you know these
elevated crosswalks and all these
different things
and of course more affluent
neighborhoods are going to get that
first this is just like
ben is projecting onto the story
his biases it's just that simple that
that's all i see here your first
question is how
right you don't ask questions typically
about the roads you don't ask questions
typically about the lights
typically you ask okay where are they
speeding and if somebody says oh they
were speeding you go oh okay well you
know that's terrible but
you know you're speeding right like you
should probably pay attention to the
traffic signs
right but if the person being killed is
the one hit by a speeder
then that's a different situation
altogether even to say just look at
whether anyone was speeding well what if
one of the two vehicles was speeding but
the person killed was not in the
speeding vehicle
then you're already looking at a traffic
design situation
this entire washington post piece is
designed specifically to ignore the
question of who is doing the speeding
because if it turns out that black
drivers are speeding more often than
white drivers that
at least partially explains the
discrepancy between black and white
death statistics
yeah it sort of does but what if the
roads in certain neighborhoods again
because traffic design hasn't been done
um lend themselves to more speeding
all right so i think we get the picture
of this
let's look at wow he went on this for
like
15 20 minutes let's look at uh
the death of the for the people act
okay looks like they block out some
stuff police morale drops
let's look at police morale drops
uh as crime rises here we go see what's
up with that oh
when you when you pursue the lie that
equal outcome is the natural state of
things
regardless of behavior and when you do
as ibrahim kennedy says and you say
well if there is a differential in
behavior then you're
implying racial inferiority i'm not
implying anything
i'm saying that there are differences in
human behavior across a wide variety
of human interactions and activities
that's just a fact saying something is a
fact doesn't make it a fact now
the truth here is there's very few
people who really see
a quality of outcome as a goal it's sort
of a straw man
um i mean there are some like i know
some actual marxists who say equality of
outcome economically for example is a
goal
but it's really not very prevalent
forget about rationale for a second that
is a simple fact
and refusal to acknowledge simple facts
on the ground means you're going to end
up not only in la la land but in
dangerous
la la land like for example undermining
the police and suggesting that the
police are responsible
for these disparities i i think i'm done
guys i mean it's just it's really really
boring stuff
um it's not even it's not even notable
in any way it's just predictable stuff
all right we're moving on
let me say thank you to bruce litvin
bruce litvin just did a heroic thing
and heroic thing signing up at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
cold feet
crowder david tryon just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
cold feet crowder ken mccourt
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code cold feet crowder very much
appreciate that
uh new members 28 29 and 30. let's get
back to some of these super chats
um where did i miss these
ah here we go oh hold on no is the
youtube is the new youtube twitch
different from patreon
uh not sure i understand the question
yeah this is i mean
yes yes it is jeremy says shapiro is so
libertarian
he sided with the corporation that made
mecca godzilla
in his godzilla vs kong review
maddie asks is this sped up if not
i'm instantly terrified charles
bergenstein says my guess is the
infrastructural racism refers to the
lack of upkeep in the predominantly
black areas
which leads to more accidents
infrastructure in black areas probably
most neglected but i don't know yeah
another version of what a few people
were saying
chris says does ben shapiro know that
talking fast doesn't make you smart
certainly there are elements of the
english language in this
he does talk fast charles adds the
upkeep of infrastructure in black areas
or non-white is not a priority and is
neglected so yes
there are more accidents that's my guess
another version of what many of us
inferred
wraith says ben needs a sound engineer
on site
newer viewer by the way all right
maddie says david sir hold on
congratulations sir you just won the
election david sir have you seen kelly
square in worcester literally the worst
intersection in the world check out the
aerial view yeah let's do that
i've not seen it i've basically not been
in worcester
uh at all kelly square
worcester massachusetts
let's see what's going on in worcester
massachusetts here
all right so let's look at
uh let's look at maybe this
whoa that seems pretty weaponized
what is even happening here
what on earth so if you're here
and you need to get here how many
crosswalks one
two three i guess
is there even sidewalk here
oh hold on sorry guys i could now i'm
realizing people couldn't see everything
yeah
um this is really weird let's take a
look at what this is like standing here
this is a mess oh my god look at this
and of course it's persistently under
construction i'm sure
um man this is really bad
this is kelly square in worcester mass
people ask me to look at this
imagine trying to get over to subway for
a fake tuna melt
and you've got to cross this stuff and
what is this little median in the middle
here like is this supposed to eventually
be something
it seems this maybe could benefit from a
rotary but i don't even know that
you could they would that it would make
sense
bizarre okay yeah thanks for calling
that to my attention
we are standing by here for joseph r
biden jr
super chats coming in oh and a big thank
you to
alex trujillo who just signed up
with the coupon code cold feet crowder
at joinpakman.com
also thanks to gordon z hall who just
re-upped
his twitch membership and his new member
number 32 today
let me see if i can get to a couple
other super chats before biden
okay i already read that one ben
probably uses auto-tune that's too fast
charles says oh hold on
conservatives would just say that it's
not the government's job to change
driver behavior
but rather a personal responsibility
issue boom
owned yes exactly ashley says hi david
big fan love the show your girlfriend is
a lucky girl wow that's
a quite a statement pathological doubt
says sorry david but this is a huge
blind spot of yours equality of outcome
absolutely is pervasive sentiment
advocated for
in academia uh i don't even think i
agree with that
in my time teaching in college and uh
you know attending
meetings and just never never ever
ever did i identify that as a goal i'm
not saying it doesn't exist i just think
it's relatively rare
daniel says you may have missed my
previous message psa re
soup okay daniel r
regarding skepticism around steven's
soup mix
important to be vocal to be a louder
crowder chowder powder
doubter a man i don't know what any of
that is about
um dr dan burrito man says
biden has not handled the border well
despite
other policies being successful could
you cover this problem please in a
detailed video
a big video about the border coming up
on tomorrow's show
taryn says i have been a longtime fan of
your show thank you taryn i appreciate
that
and charles says david sorry to bombard
you with these super chats but read
color of law by richard rothstein
it's about race-based city planning
among other stuff
sounds interesting that sounds like an
interesting topic
uh yeah you know i actually i'm going to
do a little
production here behind the scenes i'm
going to email pat
hey would you be able to clip
me talking about the mcafee death
on stream just now and publish
it as a clip to youtube
asap called
john matt you were producing the youtube
channel clip right now
john mcafee uh
found dead after
saying he would not kill
himself i mean i think that that's kind
of the natural
um title for the youtube channel
the youtube click right all right we'll
get that over to producer pat
there we go
okay good so we will get that all going
at this point in time i was typing as
fast as i was talking
any thoughts on irish reunification not
my area of expertise
no important clam chowder or lobster
bisque
oh you know i'm not a big lobster guy
like i would never order a lobster just
wouldn't do it
but from the standpoint of soup
i think i prefer lobster bisque and i
was recently
on martha's vineyard and had three
different
beautiful lobster bisques beautiful
lobster bisques you do need to have
the problem is if you want to do a real
lobster bisque
you then need to garnish it with actual
pieces of lobster meat
we can't do it the cheap way where it's
strictly a bisque
um and then you definitely want to drop
in some oyster crackers
did you hear that ben wants to ban crime
yeah that seems natural i mean what
why do we keep going back and forth with
how to reduce crime
just ban the hell out of the thing guys
why won't politicians do it ban the hell
out of crime and let's just move on and
work on something different
like uh yeah whatever
oh man i'm from maine and i don't even
eat lobster
yeah that's fine i don't think i don't
like lobster other than in a soup
format that's it
what's my typing words per minute speed
i think 140 is that high
wait is 140 my iq or my typing speed now
i don't even remember
would i prefer lobster chowder or clam
bisque
lobster chowder definitely lobster
chowder
[Music]
um is 140 high or low for typing people
are saying there's no way i type 140 but
they're not saying if that's high or low
140s fast oh okay
i think i took a test on stream a typing
test and doctors said
sir i mean we can't even believe what
you just were able to do congratulations
sir you just won the election
yeah they were shocked um
has anybody been watching copa america
argentina in typical fashion
we uh we we sucked out these one-nothing
wins
where like at any time the play was so
crappy
that it just goes 1-1 and then it's a
tie
but i mean i'm still i'm still pleased
at the winds and then we've got bolivia
on monday
which i'm hoping is going to be a uh
a really strong uh really strong showing
a few other super chats coming in david
any thoughts on the lack of hazard pay
for health care workers i feel it's been
neglected in recovery plans i am in
favor of hazard pay for health care
workers
sam says hi deepak finally got a job
since the pandemic and i'm pumped
any advice to get back into it after
being home for so many months i'm a chef
advice on getting back into what back
into the job i mean
i'm not sure i understand if you mean
just get being back out in the world
uh the fact that the vaccines are really
really effective
have i seen general mark milley on crt
okay
someone emailed me earlier and said that
there was some general
on newsmax and newsmax cut away
when he started talking about trump
winning the election is that the general
mark milly thing because i've been
trying to find a clip of that and have
not found it
anybody anybody that is the thing
where can i find a clip of that please
help me find a clip
of the general on newsmax
if that's what it is
let's see if i can find it on twitter
because i did want to see that
newsmax millie let's see if i can find
that
[Music]
actually it's not that's this seems like
something totally different
no this is a totally different thing
oh hold on this is a totally different
thing
let's see
mr here and thank you gentlemen for
joining us today i
know my time is very precious but i
would like to yield some of my time to
general milley because i know that he
had
some comments that he wanted to make
when representative gates was talking
as well as mr waltz about a similar
subject of the stand down and race
theory
would you like a minute or so to comment
on that do you remember what we were
what your line of questioning or thought
was there um
sure um first of all on the issue of
critical race
theory et cetera why is i don't even
know why a general is talking about
critical race theory but i'm curious
obviously i have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is
um but i do think it's important
actually uh for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
uh and it is important that we train and
we understand
uh and i i want to understand white rage
and i'm white
and i want to understand it so what is
it that caused
thousands of people to assault this
building
and try to overturn the constitution of
the united states of america what caused
that
i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to guys i'm kind of liking this
i'm kind of liking this a lot analyze it
it's important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians they come from the
american people
by the way guardians come on guys it's
important that the leaders
now and in the future do understand it
i've read miles seitang
i've read i've read karl marx i've read
lenin that doesn't make me a communist
so what matt gates might disagree
general what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we are here to defend
and i personally find it offensive that
we are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers of being quote woke
or something else because we're studying
some theories that are out there that
was started at harvard law school god
gates disgusts me
disgusts me years ago and it proposed
that there were laws in the united
states
anti-bellum laws prior to the civil war
that led to
a power differential with
african-americans that were
three-quarters of a human being
when this country was formed and then we
had a civil war and emancipation
proclamation
to change it and we brought it up to the
civil rights act in 1964 it took another
hundred years to change that
so look it i do want to know and i
respect your service and you and i are
both green berets
but i want to know and it matters wait
who's agree
matt gates is a green beret could that
possibly be true
what
who's he taught who's a green beret
no top general fires back at offensive
criticism
let me see here
oh oh michael waltz not matt gates okay
okay i got you i now i understand
okay military and the discipline and
cohesion of this military
and i thank you for the opportunity to
make a comment on oh i think i might
want to talk about that tomorrow
that's really interesting um let me send
that
to myself under my story folder
um very interesting that's pretty
interesting stuff
uh yeah thanks for thanks for mentioning
that to me
all right other super chats coming in
what do we have here did you see the
people canceling you on tick tock
because they think the cardi b
interview was real no is that true who
can can somebody send me a link i didn't
see that at all
oh my god that was obvious satire i
don't even know
when did that happen
let's see canceling me on tick tock
no i'm not seeing anything like that if
somebody can email me that
i would appreciate that it's going to be
tick-tock is just a nightmare to
navigate
have i see okay so mark millie we just
did watching the greece
reject matt gates getting offended by
general milly openly support critical
race theory on video is beautiful and
priceless
yes the catch 22 with cancel culture is
what is the solution to cancel it
i i did a segment about how ending
canceled culture would be
extraordinarily authoritarian
to the extent that it's that it's even
real
any updates on new york city election oh
we did a clip on that it'll be
it's gonna be published soon we're
watching euro 2020 why aren't you i
haven't watched any euro stuff i've been
watching
copa america but that's uh
that's the extent of my soccer watching
recently
okay we are now standing by for joe
biden running uh
70 minutes late i mean it is pretty
embarrassing how late they are running
um and it's very very odd
why do we have a tick tock account to
reach the kids
um david pakman show tick tock
we have a we have a pretty solid
following actually on tick tock
31 000 followers we've not been on there
very long
um let's see a bunch of scheduled stuff
where is the cardi b clip
cardi b calls in to me this was how
could people be it only got 3000 views
my ex-boyfriend that was beating my ass
i had to drop out of school
i was like um living with his mama
two peoples in a bedroom
how's i gonna leave if i only made 200
every week
ain't no way it's bleak i'm not gonna
lie but listen
we still have memes right we at least
have that
no was that an insensitive reaction to
cardi from me
i mean she told me this horrible story
and then i just say at least there's
mimetics
[Music]
okay yeah so i guess some people thought
that was real
i don't know who could there's even a
jump cut in it like it's so obviously
fake but
i guess i have to um i guess i
i don't know i mean i'm sorry guys i'm
really sorry
um a user who's
twitch username i'm not going to say
just signed up and says we need deepak
animated emotes if people want to make
animated emotes
and then also tell me how to enact them
or
enable them i'm glad to do it
but um i don't know what is going on
with animated emotes
animated emotes can be disabled i don't
think i've enabled or disabled them
i just have no idea i just have no idea
about it
um in all seriousness though now people
are asking about the clip i mentioned
someone let me tell you um i got this
email earlier if anybody can help me
find this clip i would
really appreciate it one of our viewers
wrote to me earlier and said this was
just two hours ago
david i just turned on newsmax for the
first time ever for a laugh and i was
not disappointed
at about 2 30 p.m they had this retired
united states air force lieutenant
general on to talk about some chinese
spy
about a minute into the interview the
guy spews some election nonsense saying
trump won and the host ends the
interview awkwardly
and then has to give a disclaimer about
newsmax believing the election results
and that biden is the victor it's
hilarious can anybody find that for me
i would love to actually look at that
but i've not been able to find it if you
can find that and email it to me
i would really appreciate it i think
many in our audience would appreciate
that as well
all right let's see what's going on here
75 minutes late now
[Music]
why i don't know we'll never know
[Music]
but we are stan that's just the speech
folder guy yeah that's a power move
someone else brings your speech out for
sure
um i don't expect this to go
particularly long no
but um i expect it to be
very triggering to some on the right
from the standpoint of guns
and uh oh yeah no so tomorrow
i'll be interviewing dr k
gg healthygamer.gg.com k
[Music]
yep that's tomorrow it's gonna be good
i assume people will like it yeah and
then saturday
so we are off next week
but i do plan to cover the trump rally
saturday night
assuming that um i have proper
internet because i am going to be away
and so that's going to be on saturday
night if i can get the right internet
service i just don't know yet
it's very very as many of you know
sometimes i've planned to cover things
um and then i'm not able to then i'm not
able to
i think i am probably gonna have to ban
a few people
and it's sort of uh sort of sad but it
does have to happen
um
yeah all right let's ban this user
it's like come on guys a lot of people
getting banned it's sad
yeah the healthy gamer interview i think
is going to be good we're not going to
talk to talk about gaming
but i want to talk about just what dr k
is seeing
psychologically as we start to emerge
from the pandemic are we seeing more
agoraphobia are we seeing
i mean just a lot of different things i
think it'll be it'll be super
interesting so that's going to be
tomorrow
and that will not be on twitch that will
not be on twitch that'll be recorded
and then it'll be put on the youtube
channel it'll be on the podcast the tv
show
the radio show etc etc i don't think
he's putting it on his channel
do i play dota 2 i don't even know what
that is
d o d is it defense of uh dota
man i don't even know dota 2.
i mean i know it's a game but i don't
play it
it's a moba i don't even know what that
means
i think people are just messing with me
defense of the ancients
okay very good i
uh beautiful for people who want to play
it
by all means have at it um other live
streams scheduled
yeah there there's other stuff scheduled
it's just not usually worth pre like
too much pre-promotion because uh things
get canceled things get moved around but
i have every intention of streaming the
trump rally on saturday
i think it's going to be completely nuts
and everything that
we imagine is going to take place at it
is going to take place at it
more voicemails the voicemails are
starting to get a little too edgy to be
perfectly frank
[Music]
but here's one about reparations hey
david
hey so i'm just i'm replying back so i
called about reparation
uh my name is trent bustos uh the reason
i was calling asking you about that is
because i watched
your segment on the lgbt
community and then having white people
pay
reparations and you said it was racist
to have them do that
i my question really was to you
it's racist to have an event where only
white people have to pay to get in
that because it seemed to me that you
didn't believe in recreation
and that was the reason i asked you was
there a time or a date
for like how long that happened oh okay
so this seems to be the same thing we
just addressed right
[Music]
okay hey dude this is mikey twohearted
just sent you a super chat uh definitely
user error
i've never sent a super chat before
anyway all i was going to say is thanks
for the show
and ask if you've seen the show let's be
real uh their
tucker carlson puppet is spot on
and it's quite funny i i feel like i'm
so out of it i don't know what people
are talking about
here's one about argentina hi david my
name is kenzie i
am a history teacher in the houston area
and
i've really been reading up on the
argentinian
influences with nazism uh
particularly if the german nazis fling
to argentina
and i was wondering if you had any
literature connected to that that you
would recommend
for me or if you know anything about the
topic in general
thank you so much yeah so there's
actually
there's i don't i can't cite specific
history i read on it but
um there are many examples of
so you had a lot of jews fleeing to
argentina
before during and immediately after
world war ii
but you also had nazis who were allowed
in
uh and welcomed in the aftermath
including even in the early 50s like
when my parents were born
some of them came in surreptitiously
first going to brazil
and then being brought from brazil to
argentina with new identities
um the administration of peron
and in fact one of his i forget who it
was
but peron had like a very high ranking
um
administration official who was
very involved in allowing nazis to hide
in argentina
and it's horrible and it's disgusting
and
it's a you know a very interesting
historical topic
for sure couple other voicemails
hey david long time listener here um
just have a quick question for you so my
high school
has been in the news recently because
one girl who graduated
this year wrote black lives matter
across her face
in her yearbook picture and obviously
to me it doesn't really affect me so i
don't care but
so many people in my town are completely
outraged
calling on the school to make a
statement and not allowing the yearbook
to be published because she has
quote a domestic terrorist organization
um written across her face and i would
just like to know how would you go about
explaining to the conservatives in my
town
that that black lives matter is not a
terrorist
organization well i would just ask them
to define terrorism
and then to define the acts of black
lives matter that are terroristic
just that simple that's that's the best
approach with some of these people
hi david uh so the filibuster has to go
obviously but what does it take to
reform the filibuster i mean wouldn't
they just
filibuster a bill to get rid of the
filibuster
thanks no uh no democrats could
uh change those rules uh i believe it's
because
it's a procedural it's a rules change so
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
that democrats could do it with
with the 50 plus uh tiebreak
control with kamala harris as vp
that's my uh that's my belief and that's
my understanding
i want to say thank you to mikey gaming
as well as gay music nerd and
mix zawa all of whom just signed up via
twitch prime and
related twitch subscriptions very much
appreciate that
you still can use the coupon code cold
feet crowder cold feet crowder cold feet
crowder
to get a discounted membership on my
website
electric sky says was duterte joking
about throwing the unvaccinated in jail
in the philippines i didn't even know he
said that
i had no idea and um
gesh makes says david you mentioned jews
in argentina i'm curious when your
family arrived in argentina thank you
sir congratulations sir you just won the
election
so um i need more sur drops if people
can put together more
sur drops i would like that let's see
my three of my four grandparents were
born in argentina
so it was before them my maternal
grandfather
immigrated to argentina from poland in
i kind of want to say 1924 or maybe
1929.
he was either born in 1919 and
immigrated in 1924 or was born in 19 i
think it's born in 1924
and immigrated in 1929
i believe but then beyond that my my
other three grandparents were born
in argentina i want to say thank you to
brandon blood
brandon blood just signed up at
joinpackman.com an ominous name
but we will accept the subscription
nonetheless
i think the egg man just weighed in with
something here
hey dave michael savage is still alive
you just reminded me that michael savage
is a thing
listen dave no jew believes anything
michael savage says okay right i'm a
conservative
old grumpy new york jew i come from
older more conservative more grumpy
new york jews okay they
think he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and have not
listened to him in years and years
he's completely irrelevant he's absolute
garbage he's hate speech he's a vile
messed up man
jews do not listen to that man but yes
he uses his identity
to make other people this is related to
something on today's show if you've not
listened to today's podcast that's
that's what he's referencing here
and he knows what he's talking about
about this shalom brother
god it's like the holocaust over here
with everybody comparing everything to
the holocaust right
sorry about that all right there is the
eggman
absolutely brutal attack on the english
language there
we always appreciate the eggman uh
calling in and then just a couple of
others i normally don't have this much
time but this is great
we're really getting through a lot of
material
okay we're caught up as far as
voicemails are concerned beautiful
all right um austin becker will producer
pat
defect from the david pakman show and
become your rival thanks for all that
you do
sir congratulations sir you just won the
election
um i have no idea you would have to ask
him if a defection is in order
um could be a could be a double agent of
sorts
could be a double agent of sorts we
don't know all right we are moments away
from joe biden making what has been
billed as some kind of major major
announcement about
gun safety regulations and
gun control etc i have no idea what he's
about to announce i'm as curious as you
are
and um oh people want some kind of drop
for when biden enters i don't know that
i have anything for when biden enters
china all the time nothing i have right
now really makes sense
dumps yeah like i don't know
fraud i need somebody to send me
something oh here he is
stand back and stand by that actually
does make sense okay let's listen now to
merrick garland good afternoon mr
president
it's good to be here with you and with
local elected and community leaders
and with representatives of law
enforcement right
protecting our communities from violent
crime is a top priority for the
department of justice
and one of our most important
responsibilities
i'm glad the president brought us
together today to discuss a subject of
such importance
to the public we served as our
participants in today's roundtable have
noted
the increase in violent crime in 2020
and early 2021
is deeply troubling that is why last
month
the justice department launched a
comprehensive violent crime reduction
strategy
this strategy is built around four
principles
setting strategic enforcement priorities
fostering trust with and earning
legitimacy in our communities
investing in community-based prevention
and intervention programs
and measuring the results of these
efforts
through a decrease in violent crime not
merely by arrests and convictions as if
they were ends in themselves
now we know that the lion's share of
violent crime reduction work is
shouldered by our state
local tribal and territorial law
enforcement partners
core to our strategy is targeted support
of the critical work that you will be
doing in the weeks and months ahead
every one of our u.s attorney's offices
is working with its local partners
to establish an immediate plan to
address the spike
in violent crime that typically occurs
during the summer
and the law enforcement components of
the department are making enhanced
resources available to help prevent
and disrupt violent crime and to focus
on the most dangerous
most violent offenders the department is
also strengthening
our project's safe neighborhoods our
cornerstone initiative that brings
together law enforcement and community
stakeholders
to develop solutions to pressing violent
crime problems
community-led efforts are vital to
preventing violence before it occurs
the justice department has available
over one
billion dollars in funding through over
a dozen grant programs
that can be used to support
evidence-based community
violence intervention strategies and i
want to say that's
what i found particularly useful in our
discussion just a few minutes ago
was the fact that there are such
evidence-based programs available
and i'm hoping that you will get
together with us so that we can spread
those
across the country as well of course
funding your own
a properly functioning criminal justice
system is essential to our efforts
as well the department has grant funding
available to help cities resume
court operations and services that were
curtailed during the coven 19 pandemic
that includes funding for technology and
equipment
for courts to address the backlog of
cases and enhance
access to justice we know that an effect
not a lot of gun grabbing going on huh
also address the illegal trafficking of
firearms
and focus on keeping guns out of the
wrong hands
and so the department is delivering on
the promises we made here at the white
house in april
on may 7th we issued a proposed rule to
help address the proliferation of ghost
guns
on june 7th we issued a proposed rule to
clarify that pistols equipped with
certain stabilizing braces
are subject to the same statutory
restrictions as easily concealable
short-barreled rifles and on the same
day
the department published model extreme
risk protection order legislation
for states to consider as they craft
their own laws
to reduce gun violence we are now
taking further steps first
we will hold gun dealers that break the
rules accountable
for their actions yes most federally
licensed firearms dealers operate
legally in selling guns to individuals
who have passed background checks
but those dealers that willfully violate
the law
increase the risk that guns will fall
into the wrong hands
i mean good luck proving that absent
extraordinary circumstances
atf will initiate proceedings to revoke
the licenses of dealers that
willfully violate the law this stuff is
on the books they've got to enforce
required background checks falsifying
records
failing to respond to trace requests
refusing to permit atf to conduct
inspections
or transferring firearms to persons who
are prohibited from owning them
gotta hold them accountable second we
are seeking funding to increase
atf's dealer inspection capacity and
improve its effectiveness
atf has very limited inspection
resources
the president's fiscal 2022 budget
requests
resources to add inspection positions in
every field division
the effectiveness of the enforcement
program depends on the ability to
identify
and focus on those dealers that pose the
greatest risk to public safety
starting today atf will make clear to
investigators in every field division
that as they prioritize inspections
they must consider the extent to which
firearms sold by a dealer
are later used in criminal activity
third we will improve information
sharing with state
local tribal and territorial partners to
help bring more intelligence and law
enforcement resources to bear
republicans are not going to like any of
this increase our own
accountability today atf has a point of
contact in
every field division to receive
information from mayors
police chiefs and other local leaders
about
firearms dealers they believe every
country is like you guys weren't doing
this
already and republicans are like how
dare you consider doing this
inspection data with the 16 states that
license or regulate
firearms dealers themselves also
beginning next month
atf will publicly post information about
inspection frequency
and outcomes disaggregated by field
division
providing for enhanced transparency and
accountability
right fourth we are launching a
concerted
effort to crack down on gun traffickers
yesterday the department announced that
it will establish five
new cross-jurisdictional law enforcement
strike forces
within the next 30 days uh-oh oh my god
strike forces will focus on addressing
significant firearms trafficking
corridors that fuel
violence in new york chicago
los angeles the san francisco bay area
and washington the real
shocker is none of this stuff is being
done already right how are these even
announcements
the justice department's violent crime
reduction strategy
and our initiatives to stem the rising
tide of illegal
illegal guns will save lives
but these steps alone will not
solve the problem of violent crime
success depends on all of us
joining together those of you in this
room
the many like you across the country who
are working to
keep their communities safe and the
people of our communities
themselves i would now like to introduce
president biden
who has emphasized the importance of
this issue
and who has my gratitude for gathering
us together today
thank you
thank you general let me before i begin
thank the participants on our round
table today
two mayors three mayors chiefs of police
attorneys general
and community organizers uh been doing
significant work in bringing down
violent crime in their communities
there's no one
one answer fits everything and it's
about being engaged in multiple
organizations being engaged
so i want to thank you for the time you
spent with us today and i warned you i'm
coming back at you again for more
information
and we just met as i said with a
bipartisan group of
mayors law enforcement and community
leaders
we discussed a comprehensive strategy
that
i'm releasing today to combat the
epidemic of
gun violence and other violent crime
that we've been seen in our country for
far too long that has spiked since
the start of the pandemic over a year
ago
crime is historically rises during
the summer and as we emerge from this
pandemic
with a country opening back up again the
traditional summer
summer spike may even be more pronounced
than it usually would be
for folks at home here's what you need
to know
i've been at this a long time and there
are things we know that work that reduce
gun violence and violent crime
and things that we don't know about but
things we know about
background checks for purchasing a
firearm are important
ban on assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
no one needs to have a weapon that can
fire over
30 40 50 even up to 100 rounds
unless you think the deer are wearing
kevlar vests or something
community policing and programs that
keep neighborhoods safe and keep folks
out of trouble these efforts work
they saved lives but over time
these policies were gutted or woefully
underfunded
in our conversation today we talked
about our strategy to supercharge
what works while we continue to push the
congress to act on sensible
gun violence legislation
first we discussed cracking down as you
heard from the attorney general on rogue
gun dealers
we know that if there is a strict
enforcement of background checks
then fewer guns get into the hands of
criminals biden seems more tired than
i've maybe ever seen him
more than 3 million guns out of the
hands of felons convicted felons
fugitive
domestic abusers and others prohibited
from being able to purchase a gun
and there's still too many loopholes in
that system and today
enough rogue gun dealers feel like they
they can get away with selling guns to
people who aren't legally allowed
to own them and i might add the second
amendment from the day
it was passed limited the type of people
could own a gun
and what type of weapon you could own
you couldn't buy cannon
those who say the blood of the the blood
of patriots you know
and all the stuff about how we're going
to have to move against the government
well the tree of liberty is not water in
the blood of patriots what happened is
that there are never been if you wanted
to think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some
nuclear weapons the point is that
there's always been
the ability to limit rationally limit
the type of weapon that can be owned
and who can own it the last time we had
data
on this issue of who was purchasing guns
was more than 20 years ago
five percent of gun dealers turns out
in the study we did show that 90
of illegal guns were found in the crime
scenes
sold by 5 of gun
dealers 5 so 90 of the guns found
in crime scenes and the uh these
merchants of death
are breaking the law for profit they're
selling guns that are killing innocent
people
it's wrong it's unacceptable as the
attorney general says we're going to
crack down on those gun dealers
and the violent criminals they knowingly
are
in april i announced that the justice
department is going to be issuing an
annual report on gun trafficking
so we can update that data today the
department is announcing as i just did
a major crackdown on stem the flow of
guns used to commit violent crimes
it's zero tolerance for gun dealers who
willfully
violate key existing laws and
regulations
let me repeat zero tolerance if you will
sell a gun to someone who's prohibited
from possessing it
if you willfully fail to run a
background check if you willfully
falsify a record
if you willfully fail to cooperate
obviously willfully is where
the actual uh difficulty comes in as
many of you know
your license to sell guns we'll make
sure you can't sell
death and mayhem on our streets it's an
outrage
it has to end and we'll end it period
second we discussed disrupting illegal
gun trafficking
now the gun lobby wants you to believe
that cities that are the toughest gun
had the toughest gun laws
still have the highest rates of gun
violence as was pointed out by the group
we had today in our round table
the the violence is so they argue why do
you need those
gun laws if they don't work in cities
that have tough laws
don't believe it here's the truth
today's conversation with mayor scott of
baltimore for example echoed
what we know to be the case in here for
mayors all across the country
mayors have the power to help shape and
enforce the laws in their cities
but they can't control the laws in
neighboring cities and states
even though the gun legally bought there
is often ends up in their streets
mayor scott says that 80 percent of the
guns in baltimore were acquired outside
the city
outside the city there's no he can do
about that
so we have to act as part of our
strategy the justice department
is creating five new strike forces to
crack down illegal gun trafficking
in the carters supplying weapons to
cities like new york
chicago los angeles washington d.c and
the bay area
with these straight forces local and
federal law enforcement and prosecutors
are going to be able to
better coordinate the prosecution of
illegal gun trafficking
across city and state lines so legal gun
soul from the back
door of a gun shop in virginia don't end
up in a murder scene in baltimore
and if they do then local and federal
law enforcement
can better coordinate to trace illegal
gun sales
back to a shady gun dealer and hold them
accountable
police chief murray of the baltimore uh
excuse me
police chief merrick police chief
murphy paul of baton rouge louisiana
talked about how he's coordinating more
closely with the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms
the atf and the federal bureau of
investigation the fbi
to help take on criminal organizations
committing violent crimes in the city
this kind of coordination is essential
to keeping the weapons of war out of the
hands of dangerous criminals
fugitives and gangs as well as organized
crime
third we discussed historic funding the
we discussed historic funding for states
cities and counties
and tribes for law enforcement and crime
prevention
you know they've not only had to fight
this pandemic they've also had to deal
with economic crisis
that has decimated their budgets forced
them to cut essential services including
law enforcement and social services
and amid the copa 19 pandemic they've
had to deal with a second public health
crisis
gun violence the american rescue plan
which we passed in the first hundred
days of my administration
is providing much needed historic relief
to bring back
those law enforcement jobs and social
service jobs
much of this relief has already arrived
the rest is on its way and we're now
providing more guidance on
how they can use the 350 billion dollars
nationally that the
american rescue plan has available to
help reduce crime and address the root
causes
for example cities experience an
increase in gun violence
were able to use the american rescue
plan dollars to hire police officers
needed for community policing and to pay
their overtime
mayors will also be able to buy crime
fighting technologies like
gunshot detection systems to better see
and stop
gun violence in their communities they
can use the funding to scale
we actually did a ride along with
springfield massachusetts police
a long time ago and they already had
that and some of the calls were just
going to check
on those automatic gunshot detection
systems there were a lot of false
positives at the time
the old saying my mom used to use
probably better now idle mind is a
devil's workshop
well school's out for the summer
teenagers are in tough neighborhoods
no who aren't tough neighbors no jobs
more trouble
we know summer job training summer jobs
training and recreation
for young people work they help make
sure young people pick up a paycheck
instead of a pistol
one study found in boston summer jobs
program for youth reduction
reduced violence crimes by 35 percent
boston
another study found that a program that
offers high school students in chicago
a good summer job and an adult mentor
and
behavioral therapy led to a 45 percent
drop in violence
we can invest in more of these programs
at the american rescue plan
and here's another thing states cities
counties and tribes
can do with that funding when someone
finishes their time in prison they can't
just
give them we can't just continue to give
them 25 bucks on a bus ticket
they end up right back where they
started and got them in trouble in the
first place
or no option for being able to provide
for access to public housing
or for schools or for for mentors to
help them find their way
and the stuff that prevents recidivism
and helps them
integrate into society that's changing
with guidance and issue we're issuing
today the american rescue plan funding
can help formally incarcerated people
get skills training apprenticeships and
work experience so they can gain
stability and security
and a chance for a better life rather
than going back to exactly what they
left
attorney general greenwald new jersey
and mayor
daniel and mayor daniella
levine cava of miami-dade talked about
their efforts to lift up those kinds of
community
the kinds of community programs that
reduce gun violence
keep communities safe and make real
positive difference in people's lives
for folks at home the american rescue
plan which is a once in a generation
investment to reduce
violence in america is available i'm
proud of it means
more police officers more nurses more
counselors more social workers
more community violence interrupters to
help resolve issues before they
escalated into crimes
it means we go after the people who
flood our streets with guns
and the bad actors who decide to use
them to further terrorize the
communities
it means saving lives and congress
should in no way take
away this funding it's already been
appropriated
in fact a few weeks ago the bipartisan
united states conference of mayors
the national league of cities national
association of counties
they all came out forcefully against
efforts to reclaim american rescue plan
funds
that have already been allocated to the
state cities and counties and tribes
this is not a time to turn our backs on
law enforcement or our communities
fourth we discuss the need to support
community violence intervention
these are local programs that utilize
trusted messengers
community members and leaders to work
directly
with people who are most likely to
commit gun crimes
or become victims of gun crimes we know
who they are
they intervene before it's too late
these these interrupters
turn down the temperature halt the cycle
of retaliation
connect people to social services and it
works
community violence and intervention
programs have shown a reduction
in violence up to 60 percent many places
we heard from two community leaders that
do this work
eddie uh thank you for coming from
chicago
you were really uh quite frankly it was
impressive your presentation
and uh and and devon
bogan from richmond california
um eddie was formally incarcerated
for gun homicide and davao lost his
brother to gun violence
and eddie worked as a violence
interrupter
now he runs a program that provides
high-risk men with cognitive baby
cognitive behavioral therapy to help
them
react to the impulses by slowing down
rather than following through on
the violence it puts them in he it puts
them in pays
jobs to change their trajectory the
program has reduced
has reduced shootings by 40 percent
devon runs a program across california
and six other states that
enroll high-risk individuals in peace
fellowships
complete with intensive mentoring and
social services
it's saving lives in sacramento for
example
91 of the participants stayed away from
gun violence
states and cities should invest in
american rescue plan funds and those
kinds of anti-violent crime programs
and today i'm announcing that the white
house will be working with
15 jurisdictions that are doing exactly
that
from baltimore to baton rouge to memphis
to minneapolis to build up their
community violence intervention programs
starting this summer and mayor steve
allender of rapid city south dakota a
republican former chief of police
himself
joined us today and will be part of the
effort to help disrupt cycles of crime
and violence in his community and nearby
tribal communities
we need more marriage to follow and i'm
going to be
pushing to keep pushing for more of
these proven programs
which are part of the american jobs plan
and my budget
fifth and i'll close with this we talked
about the lies we lost
have already been lost and the lives
that we can save
we talked about how much pain and loss
so many people have experienced
and so many people have now accepted
as their fate here in america we have an
opportunity to come together now
as democrats and republicans as fellow
americans to fulfill the first
responsibility of government on our
democracy
to keep each other safe
enough that means congress passing
sensible gun prevention
violence prevention initiatives is
worried it makes sense
background checks ban on assault weapons
repeal of liability shield for gun
manufacturers
it means the senate reauthorizing the
violence against women act
my proudest legislative accomplishment
to close the so-called
boyfriend loophole right it's boyfriend
and stalky loophole
to keep guns out of the hands of abusers
we added the provisions saying
if you have a stay away order you are
stalking someone and you're told that
has to stop you can't own a weapon
every single month an average of 57
women
are shot and killed by an intimate
partner
we can help stop that it means
confirming my
outstanding nominee for to lead the aft
they should be the atf david chipman
it's been without a leader for a while
the top job has been
un unconfirmed for much too long
i don't know that the reviews on this
speech are going to be particularly good
i'm worried about what we're going to
see on
fox news tonight if i'm totally honest
desperately need to fill
as vice president i pushed hard to lift
the freeze on
gun violence research to see
the center for disease control the cdc
guess what why should they not be able
to study
gun violence and what causes it but
there's been a block on it i want to
unfreeze that
as president my budget doubles funding
for the gun violence research
at the cdc and the national institutes
of health
the nih to study gun violence as a
public health threat that it is
and while we keep pushing there vice
president harris and i
also and our entire administration are
continuing to be
can we'll continue taking action where
we can
let's stop proliferation of ghost guns
as we announced back in april with the
attorney general
we need to support the development of
smart gun technologies
this doesn't affect responsible gun
owners or second amendment rights
it helps keep guns out of the hands of
people who shouldn't have in the first
place
from a child who accidentally picks up a
picks it up
to a burglar or a violent criminal
trying to steal it use it
we need to keep building on the gun
violence and crime prevention strategy
were laying out today folks this
shouldn't be
a red or blue issue it's an american
issue
we're not changing the constitution
we're enforcing it
being reasonable we're taking on the bad
actors doing bad
thing dangerous things in our
communities and to our country
talk to most responsible gun owners and
hunters
they'll tell you there's no possible
justification for having 100 rounds in a
magazine
of a gun like i said before
what do you think the deer wearing
kepler vest
gun owners will tell you that there are
too many people today
who are able to buy a gun but shouldn't
be able to buy a gun
and these kinds of reasonable reforms
have overwhelming support from american
people including gun owners
the bottom line is this let's show the
world and show ourselves
that democracy works that we can come
together as one nation
we can do this and save lives let's do
it
thank you god bless you all and may god
protect our troops and again
i thank you all for participating but
the bad news for
all of us i'm coming back stand back and
stand by thank you very
much general thank you mr president are
you still holding out hope that congress
can pass another assault weapons ban
i never give up hope how do you feel
about the bipartisan infrastructure
deal that's been released i'll tell you
that when i get the final numbers
tonight
mr president what do you feel is the
most effective thing that government can
do to change the
mindset of those who feel compelled to
pull the triggers
of these guns by being engaged in a
whole range of programs we talk today
everything from mental health programs
to engaging people early on
and letting them know there's other
options making sure that when a child is
young they
have access to real education they get
started off on the right foot
making sure that when someone gets out
of prison they're not denied public
housing they don't have to go back under
the bridge where they're living before
that they're able to get help for health
care etc
and re-engaging them in the neighborhood
giving them some hope some opportunity
and in the meantime making sure that
those folks who are taking advantage of
them by taking advantage of their
their their situation are in fact held
accountable
thank you voting rights bill do you
think it's time to reform the filibuster
congratulations sir you just won the
election
[Music]
and there he goes okay all right
so we uh we did ultimately hear from
joseph r biden jr
we um we really said it all
we really said it all and uh we will see
whether any of this becomes
a reality and that is going to do it
for today i appreciate everybody joining
me there may be a stream tomorrow but
i'm going to make every effort to stream
the trump rally on saturday night i
expect it to be dystopian in all of the
worst ways
and uh i will see everybody again very
very soon
you